♪♪
-Now, how it works is
we're gonna take turns
hitting this button here,
which activates the musical
impressions generator.
It'll land on one random singer
that we can do impressions of
and one random song title.
Whoever's turn it is
has to do an impression
of that musician
singing that song.
Since you're my guest,
why don't you go first?
-Okay.
I get so nervous for this.
I don't know why.
-So, Billie Eilish singing
"Pop Goes the Weasel."
-Oh, my God. I'm so sorry,
Billie, in advance.
-Roots.
-I love you. Okay.
♪♪
♪ All around the mulberry bush
the monkey chase the weasel ♪
♪ The monkey thought
was all in fun ♪
♪ Pop goes the weasel ♪
♪ A penny for a spool of thread,
a penny for a needle ♪
♪ That's the way
the money goes ♪
♪ Pop goes the weasel,
pop goes the weasel ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's great!
That was perfect.
-I'm so sorry.
-Alright, here we go.
It's my turn.
Alright. The Doors do
"Rubber Duckie, You're the One."
-Give me something like --
-I don't even know that song.
-"Rubber Duckie." It's Ernie.
-Oh, Ernie.
"Rubber Duck," gotcha.
♪♪
♪ -The child was taking a bath ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Bubbles surround
the young boy's head ♪
♪ Floating in the water
was a toy ♪
♪♪
♪ Rubber duckie,
you're the one ♪
♪ You make bathtime
lots of fun ♪
♪ Rubber duckie,
I'm awfully fond of you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Rubber duckie, joy of joys ♪
♪ When I squeeze you,
you make noise, yeah ♪
♪ Rubber duckie,
you're the one ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Oh, rubber duckie,
you're the one ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I didn't know
you can get up and do --
-I need props. I need props.
-And do stuff.
-No, no.
-I don't want to go after that.
-Come on, you have to.
-Okay.
-Alright, here you go.
Press the generator.
-Heart racing.
Oh, my favorite person ever.
No! I'm scared. Okay.
-Amy Winehouse doing
"Old MacDonald Had a Farm."
-Oh, my gosh.
-This is fun.
-Alright. Here I go.
♪♪
♪ Old MacDonald had a farm ♪
♪ He said, E-I-E-I-O ♪
♪ And on his farm he had a dog ♪
♪ I said, E-I-E-I-O ♪
♪ With a moo-moo here
and a moo-moo there ♪
♪ Old MacDonald had a farm ♪
♪ He said, E-I-E-I-O ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-That is correct.
That is correct.
That is exactly how you do that.
That almost was too perfect.
-Oh, come on.
-Oh, my gosh. I love that.
That was amazing. Oh, my gosh.
-That fits really well.
-Yes, it was perfect.
Now let's see what I got.
Mick Jagger doing "Baby Shark."
Okay.
-"Baby Shark."
-Now that song is gonna be
stuck in my head.
-I know.
-Oh, my gosh.
I got to get out of here.
Like a blues riff.
Yeah. Oh, yeah, "Sympathy."
♪♪
♪ Yeah, baby shark, do-do ♪
♪ Baby shark, do-do ♪
♪ Baby shark, do-do-do ♪
♪ Yeah, baby shark, do-do ♪
♪ Mommy shark
and a mommy shark, do-do ♪
♪ A grandpa shark, do-do ♪
♪ A baby shark, do-do ♪
♪ A baby shark ♪
♪ Daddy shark, daddy shark ♪
♪ A grandma shark,
a baby shark ♪
♪ Do-do, do-do, do ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got it.
[ Applause ]
-So good. That was good.
For this last one,
why don't you take us home?
Just do one more.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alanis Morissette.
-"Hush, Little Baby."
Oh, I love Alanis. Alright.
-Oh, my God.
-Roots, Alanis.
♪♪
♪ -Oh, hush, little baby,
don't say a word ♪
♪ Papa's gonna buy you
a mocking bird ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ And if that bird don't sing ♪
♪ I'll buy you a diamond ring ♪
♪ I'll buy you a diamond ring,
baby ♪
♪ And if that diamond ring
turns to brass ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Papa's gonna by you
a looking glass ♪
♪ And if that looking glass
gets broke ♪
♪ Papa's gonna buy you
a billy goat ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alessia Cara!
That's all the time we have for
"Wheel of Musical Impressions!"